Hello,
and welcome to the first tutorial on the
complete guide to Teleport.
In this tutorial, we'll be taking a look
at three ways to install Teleport
on Debian, on Red Hat,
as to any other Linux operating system using
curl.
In the following tutorial,
we'll look at Docker. So if you're looking
at containers,
jump to tutorial two.
Let's get started.
Throughout these tutorials and workshops, we'll be relying
on the Teleport documentation as much as possible.
The Teleport documentation is fantastic. And if you
ever run into trouble, I recommend checking there
first and then maybe follow-up with a YouTube
comment.
Thanks.
So let's start with Debian based distributions.
We have here a tab for Debian
with four commands.
Now you'll see here that this relies on
both curl and apt dash add dash repository.
If these are not available on your Debian
based distribution,
you will have to run an apt update
and an apt install curl
and software dash properties dash common.
This should make the tools required available.
We're going to start by copying the curl
command and dropping it onto our Debian machine.
And because I'm running as a root user,
I do not need the sudo at the
start of the second command.
This is going to import the GPG key
that will allow us to consume
the Teleport repository in a secure fashion.
Next, we're going to use the apt add
repository helper to add the Teleport repository to
our system.
And when we add the new repository with
this helper, it will automatically run the apt
update for us automatically.
So we can actually skip the next line
in the Teleport documentation
and go straight to the app install.
Voila.
We now have Teleport installed on a Debian
based distribution.
Okay.
Let's take a look at the Red Hat
version there.
If we jump back over to the documentation
and click on the Red Hat tab,
we can see that we need access to
the YUM config manager to be able to
add our Teleport repository.
To get that, you'll need to YUM install
yum dash utils.
From there, we can copy
this first command,
and this will add our Teleport repository to
our yum configuration.
Next, we do a YUM install Teleport.
We've had to click yes twice. Once to
confirm we want to install Teleport, the second
one to confirm that we wanted to import
the key from that repository.
Now the installation is running, and in just
a moment's time, we will have Teleport installed
on a Red Hat system.
And that's it. Voila.
So, well, I really appreciate
what repositories provided for Debian distributions or Debian
based distributions and Red Hat based distributions.
Sometimes you just wanna install it yourself,
or maybe you're just running another
more esoteric
distribution.
In fact, I'm a pretty big fan of
Arch.
So let's take a look at how we
can install Teleport without the package repositories.
On the installation instructions, I've clicked on ARM
64 ARM v eight instructions. Now these aren't
specific to ARM.
However, they are highlighting that we can use
curl commands to install Teleport.
I'm gonna copy this first one, which downloads
the SHA two fifty six. This is the
checksum for the binary that we are about
to download.
When I paste it though, I'm gonna make
a small change
because this isn't an ARM 64
machine. It is a standard AMD sixty four
machine.
However, because it's Arch Linux, we can't leverage
those package repositories.
So we're going to download that checksum.
Next, we can copy the curl command
for downloading a binary artifact.
And, again, we're going to replace ARM 64
with AND
64.
Now that we have the TARBOL downloaded, we
can copy the SHA sum command to verify
and validate that the checksum and the TARBOL
match.
This command is slightly different on R's Linux.
The command is SHA sum SHA two five
six sum, and it doesn't need us to
tell it the size.
Oh, and we have to update the ARM
64 to EMT 64.
I was bound to forget it once.
What we can see here is that the
ShaSM we downloaded here
matches
the shadow we get on the tarball.
That's exactly what we want.
Lastly, we can extract our downloaded tarball,
c d into the Teleport directory,
and run the installation script.
Voila. Teleport installed on any Linux distribution
using curl,
something to check the Chasms,
and one helper install script.
Now that we've seen three different ways to
install Teleport, let's actually kick the tires on
it and make sure it works.
Without any configuration,
we can run Teleport start on any of
these installations
and get a Teleport server running.
Because there is no TLS configuration provided by
me, the end user,
it's going to generate some certs that may
be considered insecure or unsafe by your browser.
In the workshop coming up in just a
few days' time, you will see how to
provision and use the built in support for
Let's Encrypt to get real x five zero
nine certificates that are trusted by all browsers.
If you also get this screen,
Chrome allows you to type this is unsafe
anywhere on the page, and it will accept
the untrusted certificate.
And perfect.
We now have a Teleport login screen that
will allow us to access this Teleport service.
But wait, we haven't created any users.
We can add our first user from the
Linux system
by using the t c t l command.
The t c l command has a subcommand
called users and a following subcommand called add.
We can provide the name of the user
that we wish to add.
We're gonna have to assign
some roles and privileges to this user. Now
you don't have to worry about this right
now. We will cover this in a future
tutorial and workshop.
After adding user, you will be presented with
an ephemeral
short lived token that will allow you to
register and create your first user.
I have to change the container
to localhost
for this to work.
Now we just have to set a password
and configure 2FA.
Teleport is secure by default and in fact
cannot be misconfigured to not support 2FA.
So you're gonna wanna use Google Authenticator,
1Password, that word in, or even Authy. Whatever
you wanna use, you can configure.
Teleport does support hardware tokens as a 2FA,
and this will be covered in future sessions.
1Password provides support for scanning this QR code
directly through the extension.
And now we have created and logged in
to our Teleport server.
So now that we have access, let's see
what we can do with Teleport.
First, I'll zoom in a little bit to
make it a little bit more legible.
We start off on a server screen.
This lists all of the nodes which have
a Teleport agent running within your cluster.
There is a connect button that when clicked
allows you to SSH
securely with auditing
to any machine within the cluster.
You have access to whatever users you're configured
access to. If you remember when I ran
a tctl user to ads command, I gave
myself dash dash logins equals root.
We haven't discussed user management yet, but we
will do this soon in a future session.
If I click connect as root, we get
a web based SSH
terminal.
From here, I can run commands.
I can ask who I am and I
can look to see which other processes are
running within the system.
I'm going to click exit, and we'll let
that go away.
Now, we haven't configured this Teleport with much
more at the moment,
but what I will say is that there
is a lot coming
when we look at application
management,
Kubernetes
and databases.
Teleport provides primitive for securely managing with protocol
awareness,
access to Postgres,
MongoDB,
and more coming soon.
It has first class support for hooking into
your Kubernetes system and giving people access to
the clusters as required.
You can also proxy any application running within
a Kubernetes cluster or on any bare metal
node
provided you can tell Teleport where that application
is.
You can distribute access to that as an
ephemeral fashion or persistent,
giving people what they need access to in
a really easy, simple fashion.
What we can see just now in this
unconfigured Teleport though, is activity and auditing.
If I click on activity here
and active sessions, you'll see that we don't
actually have an active session right now.
But let's just change that and open our
new root session.
We'll jump back over to here, click on
active sessions, and you can see
the session is now listed here. We can
see the ID, we can see the user
and the IP address, and the note that
was accessed.
And if I wanted, I could click the
join the session to get a second tab
typing in real time with my collaborator.
If I move over here,
you can see every single thing, even when
I don't hit return,
that is happening in this session.
More importantly than that is we get full
auditability of everything happening in this system. You
can see when the user was created.
You can see when sessions are started.
You can click on it for more information
to see which login was used
and which user initiated the session.
You can see when they disconnected,
you can see when a session ends,
and you can even see when a user
joins an active session.
There is a wealth of information here for
the next time you have
any risky situation.
And my favorite feature,
session recording.
Teleport records all of the activity on the
sessions, allowing you to play it back as
everywhere a movie even though it's not.
We can click play on a session here
and see every command that I executed
at the start of this demo.
More than that, you can see that there's
a slider that allows us to roll this
back to whatever stage of the history we
want.
And one last thing,
you can copy and paste anything
from the recording.
So that is my high level overview of
Teleport.
You've seen how to install Teleport on Debian,
Rata, and with Curl.
You've seen how to start the server and
create your first user.
We've done a high level exploration of the
user interface and discussed briefly some of the
features we're gonna be looking at in this
course.
Join us for our workshop.
In just a few days' time, we will
be taking a look at all of these
features in much
more detail in a live hands on fashion.
We'll see you soon.